a player who's been out of the NFL will
have his closest encounter with the
league since he caused a storm of
controversy three years ago the NFL
organized a workout for Colin Kaepernick
today in Atlanta the former San
Francisco 49ers quarterback polarized
the public in 2016 when he began
protesting police brutality and
injustice by not standing for the
national anthem Kenneth Craig is here
with more Kenneth how's it looking well
good morning to you Michelle at least 11
teams so far have RSVP'd for the workout
it is unusual for the NFL to host
something like this and for a single
player and especially one as
controversial as Kaepernick and that's
led some football insiders to wonder why
5 a.m. 5 days a week for three years
still ready Colin Kaepernick is finally
getting the shot he's been waiting for a
chance to make an NFL roster I have no
idea why the NFL's
done this is the question on everyone's
mind is why now and it'll be nearly
three years since Colin Kaepernick's
last game Kaepernick hasn't played in
the NFL since January 2017 his pregame
protests over police brutality during
the national anthem at first by sitting
and then kneeling ignited a firestorm
Kaepernick sued the NFL for colluding to
keep him out of the league the two sides
settled in February I think the NFL has
had enough
blowback from the media from fans from
narrative from people around Kaepernick
from players why isn't this guy getting
a chance
former Green Bay Packers Vice President
Andrew Brandt says the NFL felt like it
had to do something this is telling
Kaepernick and the world these teams to
see him it's not our fault if they don't
sign them hey don't blame us more than a
dozen teams are expected to attend
today's workout in Atlanta Brant calls
the mid-season tryouts unprecedented
there will be no head coaches at this
workout and likely there will be no
general managers at this work I think
the likelihood that Kaepernick is signed
this year is slim to none I think
the best-case result for colin
kaepernick out of this workout is
signing what is called a futures
contract for 2020 and beyond and video
of Kaepernick's workout and interview
will be made available to all 32 NFL
teams unclear whether we will see any of
the workout today but it's clear yeah
he's been preparing for this for a long
time yeah
I'm interested to hear what the court of
public opinion has to say about this
after the workout he should be two years
old now yeah yeah it'll be interesting
looks like he's ready to play yeah Kenna
thank you very much